un neurólogo está probando el efecto de
un fármaco sobre el tiempo de respuesta
inyectando 100 ratas con una 2 unitaria
exponiendo las individualmente estímulos
neurológicos y registrando el tiempo de
respuesta el neurólogo sabe que la media
del tiempo de respuesta para las ratas
que no han sido inyectadas con el
fármaco es de 1.2 segundos la media del
tiempo de respuesta de las 100 ratas
inyectadas es de 1.05 segundos con una
desviación estándar de 0.5 segundos
piensas que el fármaco ha tenido algún
efecto en el tiempo de respuesta para
hacer esto vamos a establecer dos
hipótesis la primera hipótesis es
llamada la hipótesis nula y establece
que el fármaco no tiene ningún efecto en
el tiempo de respuesta esta hipótesis
nula va a ser como el status quo asumes
que lo que estás investigando no tiene
ningún efecto así que la hipótesis nula
va a ser el fármaco no tiene efecto el
fármaco no tiene efecto otra manera de
pensar en esto es que la media de las
ratas que están usando el fármaco debe
ser igual a la media de las ratas que no
lo están usando es decir la media con el
fármaco mejor déjame escribirlo de esta
otra manera el tiempo medio va a ser
igual el tipo de respuesta va a ser
igual a 1.2 segundos aún con el fármaco
aún con el fármaco eso básicamente está
estableciendo que no tiene efecto porque
sabemos que si no se aplica el fármaco
el tiempo medio de respuesta es de 1.2
segundos necesitamos ahora la hipótesis
alternativa y esta hipótesis sería bueno
pensamos que el fármaco si tiene un
efecto entonces la hipótesis alternativa
es
el fármaco
tiene efecto tiene un efecto lo cual
equivale a que el tiempo promedio de
respuesta es distinto de 1.2 segundos
cuando se aplica el fármaco cuando se
aplica el fármaco como sabemos y debe
aceptar la hipótesis alternativa o
deberíamos por default aceptar la
hipótesis nula pues los datos no son
convincentes y la manera en la que lo
vamos a hacer en este vídeo la cual es
muy similar a lo que se hace usualmente
en la investigación científica es decir
ok supongamos que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera si la hipótesis no es
verdadera cuál es la probabilidad de
obtener los resultados que se obtuvieron
con la muestra y si esa probabilidad es
real realmente pequeña entonces lo más
seguro es que la hipótesis nula no es
verdadera rechazaríamos la hipótesis
nula y plantearemos que bueno pensamos
que el i-pod es alternativa es la
adecuada así que hagamos eso
supongamos supongamos que la hipótesis
nula es verdadera asumiendo que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera calculemos
cuál es la probabilidad de que hayamos
obtenido ese resultado es decir una
media muestral de 1.05 segundos y una
desviación estándar de punto cinco
segundos así que lo que quiero hacer es
suponiendo la hipótesis nula
quiero saber cuál es la probabilidad de
hecho de hecho no quiero tan solo la
probabilidad de esto yo la probabilidad
de obtener este resultado o un valor
inclusive más extremo que tan probable
sería un evento como este para esto
pensemos en la distribución muestral de
medias suponiendo la hipótesis nula
entonces la distribución muestral sería
algo así sería una distribución normal
tenemos un muy buen tamaño de muestra
una muestra de 100 y aquí tendríamos la
media de la distribución muestral ahora
suponiendo la hipótesis nula la media de
la distribución muestral la media
distribución muestral va a ser igual a
la media de la población la cual es
igual a 1.2 segundos ahora cuál es la
desviación estándar de la distribución
muestral la desviación estándar de la
distribución muestral va a ser igual a
la desviación estándar de la población
dividido entre la raíz cuadrada del
tamaño de muestra es decir dividido
entre la raíz de 100 no sabemos la
desviación estándar de la población pero
lo que vamos a hacer es la vamos a
estimar a partir de la desviación
estándar de la muestra dado que tenemos
un muy buen tamaño de muestra tenemos un
tamaño de muestra igual a 100 así que
esta esta de aquí va a ser una muy buena
aproximación para esta de acá así que
podemos decir que esto es aproxima
igual a la desviación estándar de la
muestra sobre la raíz de 100 y esto es
muestra la cual es igual a punto 5
segundos
punto 0.5 segundos dividido entre la
raíz de 100 que es igual a 10.5 dividido
entre 10 es igual a punto 05 entonces la
desviación estándar de la distribución
muestral
la desviación estándar la instrucción
muestral va a ser igual y vamos a
ponerle un sombrerito aquí porque
estamos estimando con la desviación
estándar de la muestra la desviación
estándar de la población entonces por
eso el sombrerito para decir que es un
estimador va a ser punto 5 entre 10 que
es igual a 0.05 entonces cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener un valor de 1.05
otra manera de verlo es a cuántas
desviaciones estándar con respecto a la
media está 1.05 y cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener un valor que
esté alejado al menos ese número de
desviaciones estándar con respecto a la
media calculemos entonces a cuántas
desviaciones está el valor de la media y
esencialmente es
calcular el puntaje z para este
resultado déjame agarrar un nuevo color
voy a agarrar el naranja no he utilizado
aún el naranja entonces el puntaje z o
también podemos denominarlo el
estadístico z el cual se calcula a
partir de estos otros estadísticos
muestrales entonces nuestro estadístico
z va a ser igual qué tan lejos estamos
de la media la media es
12 - el valor de la media la muestra que
es 1.05 lovato poner en unidades
positivas eso es qué tan lejos estamos
de la media y si lo queremos en términos
de la desviación estándar lo que vamos a
hacer es dividir por nuestra mejor
estimación de la distribución de perdón
de la desviación estándar de la
instrucción muestra de medias y la cual
estimamos hace unos momentos que era
0.05 entonces aquí tenemos 0.05 y
nuestro estadístico z va a ser igual a
1.2 menos 1.0 51.2 menos 1.0 5 es punto
15 dividido entre punto 0 5.15 entre
punto 05 es igual a 3 entonces este
resultado de aquí
hemos visto que está a tres desviaciones
estándar con respecto a la media déjame
dibujarlo una desviación estándar dos
desviaciones estándar tres desviaciones
estándar por el lado positivo y por el
lado negativo deja de hacer lo mejor
deja no fue una muy buena curva de
campana pero déjame que tener una mejor
escala aquí tenemos una desviación
estándar dos desviaciones estándar tres
desviaciones estándar por el lado
positivo y por lado negativo tenemos una
desviación estándar dos desviaciones
estándar y tres desviaciones estándar
entonces este resultado de 1.05 segundos
que obtuvimos de una muestra de 100
ratas se ubica aquí a tres desviaciones
estándar por debajo de la media ahora
cuál la problema tener un resultado tan
extremo simplemente debido al azar y
cuando digo un resultado tan extremo
como este me refiero a un resultado que
esté por abajo de tres dedicaciones
estándar con respecto a la media o
también un resultado que esté por arriba
de tres desviaciones estándar con
respecto a la media básicamente cuando
estamos pensando en calcular publidad de
un resultado más extremo que éste
estamos pensando en calcular el área
bajo la curva normal
ambos extremos por la parte negativa y
por la parte positiva cuál es la
probabilidad sabemos por la regla
empírica que 99.7 por ciento de
probabilidad se encuentra dentro de tres
desviaciones estándar entonces este
valor de aquí y bueno siempre puedes
buscar una tabla zeta el valor aunque
tres desviaciones estándar es un número
entero muy fácil y no está por demás
recordar lo sabemos entonces que esta
área va a poner en una naranja o
naranjas rosado sabemos entonces que
esta área vale 99.7 por ciento de
probabilidad entonces que lo que nos
queden estas son las rosas los que en
estas zonas rosas pues la diferencia sea
que 99.7 por ciento en estas dos
combinadas va a haber punto 3 % punto 3
por ciento va a haber en estas dos zonas
combinadas
podemos escribir lo mejor como 0.3 por
ciento o si lo escribimos en fracción si
lo escribimos en fracción va a ser igual
a punto 0 03 del área total bajo la
curva así que para contestar a la
pregunta si suponemos que el fármaco no
tiene efecto la probabilidad de obtener
una muestra tan extrema o de hecho más
extrema que ésta es de tan solo punto 3
% menos de 1 en 300 así que si la
hipótesis nula es verdadera hay tan sólo
una probabilidad de 1 entre 300 de
obtener un resultado tanto o más extremo
que este así desde mi perspectiva este
resultado favorece la hipótesis
alternativa voy a rechazar voy a
rechazar la hipótesis nula tenemos que
rechazar la hipótesis nula no estoy 100%
seguro pero si la hipótesis nula fuera
verdadera
hay tan sólo una probabilidad en 300 de
obtener esto así que voy por la
hipótesis alternativa y para darte un
poco del bagaje
que conozcas la nomenclatura que se usa
en estadística en los trabajos de
investigación científica que se publica
la probabilidad de obtener un resultado
tan extremo como esté dada que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera se conoce
como el valor p entonces el valor p el
valor p aquí lo cual se deriva del valor
de probabilidad es igual a punto 0 0 3
así que hay una probabilidad muy muy
baja de obtener este resultado si la
hipótesis nula fuera verdadera por lo
cual la rechazamos y en general en la
mayor de los casos se pone un valor
límite si tienes un valor p de menos de
5% lo que significa menos de 1 en 20
entonces sabes que vamos a rechazar la
hipótesis nula hay una probabilidad
menor de 1 en 20 de obtener ese
resultado aquí obtuvimos un valor mucho
menor de 1 en 20 hay una fuerte
evidencia de que la hipótesis nule es
incorrecta y el fármaco definitivamente
tiene algún efecto